hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
shiny new Avengers clip out so I thought
it was time to do a new bonus video and
since I haven't talked about Loki in a
while I wanted to talk about what he's
been doing while age of Ultron is going
on because the next time we're gonna see
him you know that it's been confirmed is
Thor 3 Idris Elba did spoil a few things
but I won't repeat those here just in
case you guys haven't read on me and you
don't want spoilers for any of the
movies before Thor 3 most of you
probably know what I'm talking about
though I know there were some Captain
America Civil War rumors I'll talk about
those after I get through Loki Avengers
Thor 3 stuff so just add some context
most of you probably know thor 3 is
called Ragnarok and you're probably
familiar with the Thor clone called
Ragnarok really he's like an Android
clone that Tony Stark created during
civil war in the comics that's not gonna
be with the Thor 3 movies about it'll be
a proper Thor movie in space it'll be
closer to what Jack Kirby and Stan Lee
did in tales of Asgard they did a
Ragnarok storyline in that if you have
Marvel unlimited you can read it for
free it's it's a great classic story
Loki leads an invading force against
Asgard kinda like he did in the first
Thor movie including the Firelord sorter
who breaks Asgard most of them die in a
bunch of reborn after the fact cut up
Ken reinvigorating the characters
there's a really cool story behind the
story with respect to Stan Lee Jack
Kirby's Ragnarok it has a lot to do with
Jack Kirby's fourth world like he
basically he wanted to kill all the Thor
characters and give birth to the new
gods like they were gonna replace the
Asgardian characters in the comics in
Marvel Comics the rumor is is that Jack
Kirby wanted to own his fourth world
characters and Marvel wasn't down with
that they were they were just doing
creator for higher stuff so he took them
to DC so that's why DC has the new gods
obviously Jack Kirby went on to a great
career at DC but it's just a really
interesting story about how he was gonna
destroy all the Thor characters in the
comics which I thought was pretty funny
as you'd expect Marvel's gonna take
aspects of that story and adapt it into
their movie universe obviously they
always changed like little things based
on characters they've already developed
or elements that they're working with in
other movies like the way they changed
the guardians of the galaxy backstory
changing Ultron's backstory you get the
idea and a lot of you are asking like
how all these phase 3 movies are gonna
fit together because there's way more of
them than there were during phase 2 so
what's going to happen is is some of
them will pick up in the same timeline
even though they come out like you know
six months after each other
some of them will occur in the same
timeframe so Avengers age of Ultron ends
Captain America Civil War picks up right
after that and then a couple movies
later for three also picks up right
after that it sounds weirder than it is
here's the actual Phase three lineup so
Captain America's Civil War is the
beginning of Phase three that comes
right after ant-man
ant-man is like the tail end of Phase
two then comes dr. strange guardians to
thor ragnarok Avengers infinity War part
1 black panther Captain Marvel infinity
War part 2 and then Inhumans is shutting
down phase 3 before phase 4 starts if
you guys listen to Chris Hardwick's
Nerdist podcast he just interviewed
Brian Michael Bendis and Bendis said
that he is reading phase 4 scripts right
now like they're actually writing those
movies so he said they're really
exciting but he couldn't say anything
about him just working in Reverse from
infinity war to age of ultron infinity
war is supposed to be like where
goes crazy on a galactic scale
everyone's fighting each other big war
in space think of Thor 3 is like the
bomb that goes off that makes everything
explode Ragnarok is all about the idea
of destruction and rebirth so as stuff
starts to go crazy through phase 3
there'll be you know something of a
metaphorical rebirth of characters and
literally some stuff will be destroyed
and new stuff will be born out of it the
most important person in all this as you
would expect is Loki not only because
he's a big part of the original Ragnarok
story but because he is a master at
playing both sides so what does he have
to do with what's going on in the
vengers age of Ultron well think about
it this way Tony Stark takes a very
notable scepter puts it in his lab you
know it accidentally helps create a
sentient robot that wants to kill
everyone Loki needs to get that back if
you guys remember during that Marvel
phase 3 announcement Kevin Feige did a
Q&A where he thankfully confirmed the
mind gem is in Loki's scepter that plays
a big role in the creation of Scarlet
Witch Quicksilver and Ultron we don't
really know about vision it could have
something to do with the creation of
vision but there's a lot of rumors that
the soul gem could have something to do
with that too the only thing we know is
confirmed is Loki's scepter and during
the first Avengers movie it was given to
him on loan by Thanos Thanos gave him
the
and an army of Chitauri warriors in
exchange for retrieving the tesseract
none of those things ended up happening
he didn't take the earth the army was
destroyed and the scepter was left in
the possession of humans so at some
point
Thanos is going to collect so Loki is
going to have to do something to get
that back while he's masquerading as
Odin Loki also has possession or at
least access to the Infinity Gauntlet
which was last seen in Odin's vault I
don't think we've seen it since the
first Thor movie which is actually a
long long time ago so let's just assume
it's still there unless told otherwise
after the first Avengers movie they also
took the tesseract back there although
it didn't seem like it was referenced
during Thor the dark world if you
remember at the beginning of that movie
when he first meets with Jane Foster he
explains the relics that predate the
universe that was him talking about the
Infinity stones there's a lot of
unanswered questions as to why Loki
would want a free Serdar why it would
end up destroying Asgard but it probably
has something to do with him and Thanos
in their relationship Loki wants to be
king of Asgard more than anything he
made a deal that he did not fulfill so
maybe that's what leads to Ragnarok and
a lot of you are asking where is Odin in
all this what happened to him at the end
of dark world Anthony Hopkins said some
very ominous things but it's all
conjecture it was just him speculating
he made some offhanded comments saying
like you know I've made two films that's
enough I'm done I don't know what
happened to him maybe he's dead really I
think Odin is just stuck in their
version of the afterlife with Halle I
think that thor ragnarok will deal with
that idea like the idea of the Asgardian
afterlife basically all the things that
you've wanted to see but they haven't
done in movies yet the reason that idea
gets me really excited because you know
if Thor is going to beat Loki in Thor
Ragnarok who's gonna be like Thor versus
Loki then that means that Thor might
take possession of the odinforce by the
end and it'll become the Thor force
that's basically Odin's life force over
the last 50 years they've explored the
powers that the odinforce gives Odin and
Thor in a lot of different ways but
basically it is like the most powerful
cosmic force you can have next to
infinity stones which means it could
play a big role in infinity war part 2
Thor is rumoured to be absent in
infinity War part 1 but I don't think
they would leave him out of part 2 and
if you're gonna fight someone who has
all of the Infinity stones when you want
someone
who is in possession of the odinforce
that's all speculation but I just I feel
like before Chris Hemsworth vacates the
role like in his last couple of films
they're gonna elevate him to king of
Asgard and in order to do that he's gets
to go through this big crucible which
you know implies that he might die and
then come back to life it's always fun
to see like older versions of Thor from
the future in the comics he acts a lot
more like Odin he's way crumbier he's
way less fun there was a comic recently
that kind of bound a bunch of Thor's
across space and time to fight this one
single villain the older Thor always
tells young Thor kill your brother now
don't wait kill him now it's so dark and
so awesome I know there were a lot of
questions after like one of the last
Avengers trailers because you see Thor
thrashing around and this woman that
looks kind of like kala I think he'll
hallucinate the Asgardian afterlife like
he'll hallucinate some Norse gods
Scarlet Witch is gonna be doing just
some awesome things with their brains so
I think that's where we'll get our first
taste of the Asgardian afterlife but it
will be a hallucination it won't be like
Thor actually dying it'll be him
hallucinating it speaking of galactic
war I know everyone's wondering what's
gonna happen to Ultron at the end of
Avengers 2 because they can't leave him
on earth because they'll just inhabit
other technology in the comics it's
actually really cool he was the reason
that the first guardians team got
together he started annihilation
conquest because the first guardians
movie changed a lot of their backstory
they can still do anihilation conquest
in the future so they could do that for
like guardians 3 I'm not expecting to
see Ultron during infinity war but it is
totally possible it's been so long since
we've seen Red Skull that it's like you
know once they retire a big villain once
they beat him usually they don't come
back right away so here's my big
question for you guys
Loki needs the scepter scepter still on
earth in age of Ultron how do you think
that Loki is gonna get the scepter back
I know it all sounds a little bit
complicated like with all these phase 3
movies especially the ideas of Ragnarok
and how it all ties together don't worry
though
Marvel basically makes these movies so
that you can go in cold even if you
don't read comics you haven't seen any
of the other ones you should be able to
follow each of the movies I will say
though it's a lot more fun if you get
Marvel unlimited and just go on their
basic recommendations they do have like
movie rails where it's like hey learn
more about these stories from the movies
usually I try to make suggestions like
The Avengers age of Ultron story video
that I did
but just browse around it's like the
best way to spend a Saturday afternoon
and it's super cheap and just to address
the Captain America rumors Captain
America Civil War the rumor is is that
an Avenger will die during age of Ultron
and they won't be part of Civil War most
of the Avengers appear in Civil War but
there's been like a lot of posters with
one notable omission so people are like
oh that characters probably one that
died is the one that's missing in case
you don't want spoilers don't worry I'm
not gonna mention that character's name
from what I've read the rumor is born
out of an old version of the shooting
script for age of Ultron personally I
would just ignore it they actually they
start shooting Captain America Civil War
April 1st I know it sounds like April
Fool's like it's a joke but it's not a
joke they are actually shooting so in
case you guys haven't seen it yet you
can click here for my last Avengers
trailer breakdown so much fun we get to
see the vision finally finally and you
can click here to learn all about
Scarlet Witch in the comics obviously
the movie is doing a little bit
different but I tried to incorporate
that into the video so thank you so much
for watching I know since all you guys
want high fives to come back I'll say
high fives see you guys tomorrow
you